and you end up going slower
because you you just
wait where the hell is he going
he's leaving already
just looking at the pin location guys
oh my gosh
no i'm just kidding i'm so freaking lost
around here i don't know where i'm going
i gotta get underneath these ropes
somehow because there's water here here
we go
my guy got me thanks man
next on the t
seven time super bowl champion
never started an nfl season owen 2 but
is owen 2 in the match
tom brady
thanks guys
thanks ernie
all right that was a good looking
dancing
dancing now now we let the pro go
[Laughter]
jj i'm gonna get you yeah yeah no don't
worry it's not seven super bowls you
know i got zero just let me have it tom
that's right i'm gonna hit you come over
here i'm gonna unnecessary roughness you
hey
ask josh if he's ever seen one of these
have you ever seen one of these
do you know what that is i've seen one
before
seen it okay
there it is
thanks all right so i got a free run now
ryden who's back
let me tell you tom brady's second at
the par five second
oh
my goodness
there it
that was is
nice sugar
giving that to him
it's up to you bro
oh come on you want to go prison
[Laughter]
oh wait see that's why you put it
that's not bad that's that's not good
it's better than the bladed chip that's
why i would have putted it
hey i prepared for the day too at that
blackjack table last night
all right brady looked a little heavy
gotta go
oh wow
all right
good job sorry shot
safe one currently a little chunky i
call that a little josh alani
they'll fix that one
all right
it's a hell of a putt though
[Applause]
tom let me tell you your posture looks
great the swing is fine but you need to
feel like you're swinging more to the
right
swing more to the right with your hands
and arms
oh my he hit it to the right
thanks a lot
thanks
i said swing to the right not hit it to
the right
that's sweet i think that's
some tip you gave me oh yeah
okay i see i see
nice shot tom
[Music]
he's already had one closest to the
fin today
[Music]
thanks guys
[Music]
[Applause]
all right brady they're in three at the
par five seventh
wow
is that
looking good
yeah nicely done
nicely done
you know tom is great at needling that
little thing he said to josh allen to
start today was hilarious when you talk
about it he says he went to a college i
never heard of and now you're playing a
ball i've never heard
it's pretty funny
meantime back at the match he said he's
busy that week
here's tom going with that
hybrid again yeah it's a shot he likes
obviously well clearly he's liking it
way too much
this as long as i've been in vegas
without drinking in 30 years
oh
look at that nice and smooth
baby just like whatever's in there all
right
that is coming right out well we can't
see it i can't see anything yeah it's
going to be short of us so he just went
to the hybrid
oh nice shot tom very good right in the
middle
ooh that's a good shot there
hey guys grabbed a little bit for him
that was good
[Applause]
very well played
oh
it's a good putt
that's tough
we are gonna go to the 12th
all tied up
[Applause]
staring it down
how about you oh
wow that's a good shot though whatever's
right at the pit it's a good shot
see a little heat on this one
oh yeah
i gotta leave a mark
sorry player no harm no problem
oh my god
it's a nice putt king of the hail mary
comes through at the end with a
beautiful putt
what a great finish he played awesome
wow you
that was awesome great playing